Welcome back to New Rockstars, I’m Erik Voss, and Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of Madness’
WandaVision connection just went from static to clear signal with Kevin Feige confirming Doctor
Strange was originally planned to appear in the WandaVision finale, the source of
those never-explained commercials, but this was removed, causing a rewrite to Multiverse of
Madness, and helping debunked nerd theorists like me sleep again. You cut
Doctor Strange and the bunny turning into a hell demon, but keep Ralph Bohner? COOL.
These reveals tell us a lot about how the Scarlet Witch will return in Multiverse of Madness,
and really, WHAT WAS DOCTOR STRANGE’S PLAN during the events of WandaVision? I'm gonna explain it
all but SPOILER WARNING in case my theories are right but if not I don’t care because it’s more
fun to be surprised. So Kevin Feige confirmed Doctor Strange was going to appear in the
WandaVision finale, but was written out, because they didn’t want to overshadow Wanda’s
story with a bigger-name Avenger stealing focus. WandaVision head writer Jac Schaeffer revealed
that the commercials were planned to be messages from Strange to Wanda, and that Strange was going
to appear in one of the ads. Looking back, the commercials were one thing I actually managed to
theorize correctly, predicting that the final ad would be one for anti-depressant
medication. And now that we know these were all messages
from Doctor Strange, that changes so much about how we understand WandaVision. In Episode 4, we
learned that everything WE had been seeing as part of Wanda’s sitcom reality was being broadcasted out
on local frequencies, being picked up on Darcy’s AV equipment. That includes the commercials.
The commercials were for The Stark Toast Mate 2000, the Strucker Watch, Hydra Soak
bath soap, Lagos paper towels, Yo-Magic kids yogurt, and Nexus antidepressants. Actually
right as WandaVision began, Feige was asked about these, responding in some choice
language: “That was part of something early on…. How are other truths of the show beginning
to leak out? And commercials were an early idea for that. And if this is the very first Marvel
MCU thing you’re watching, it’s just a strange. It’s just a strange version of the ’50s commercial or ’60s commercial
that you’ll have to keep watching the series to understand. STRANGE. The answer was right there,
all along, the whole time. But before Ii continue
thanks to keeps for sponsoring this video losing
your hair can be a boomer sometimes i'm over here
pulling my hair out trying to figure out these
theories and find all the easter eggs but i don't
want it to be falling out on its own well two out
of three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time they're 35
i know guys in my life that are stressed about it
with keeps it's easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and to keep the hair
that you have keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products out there
but at half the cost of your local pharmacy like
you used to have to go to the doctor's office for
this kind of treatment but with keeps you can do
it all from home you meet with a doctor online
and they ship the treatment right to you every
three months so you don't have to wait in line at
the pharmacy find out why keep says more five star
reviews than any of its competitors and nearly 100
000 men trust keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication so if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com new rockstars
or click the link in the description to receive
50 off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash new rockstars now episode eight confirmed
to the many theories that the commercials were
linking to wanda's history like the mysterious
red colored beeping of the stark toaster was
indeed wanda's subconscious reminding her of
the stark bomb that traumatized her in pietro
the strucker watch and hydra soak were nods
to her time with baron von strucker in the
hydra lab lagos paper towels referenced her
guilt for the casualty she caused in lagos
nigeria the beginning of civil war but yo magic
yogurt and nexus antidepressant remained a bit
up for interpretation like sure you could
say they're reflections of wanda's sorcery
and status as a nexus level being that's the score
of the witch nexus meaning a marvel being that can
detach oneself from any one reality but the series
itself never explicitly confirmed that intention
until now with this doctor strange reveal the west
view hex with its shifty and sitcom aesthetic was
mostly wanda's doing of course but other sorcerers
could use their magic to meddle within that
hex agatha harkness arrived after it began and
manipulated wanda within it trying to steal her
sorcery but doctor strange was also interfering
via these commercials his interrupted messages
took the form of classic television because
like everything in the hex wanda sorcery warped
strange's messages to fit the broader aesthetic
and the fact that wanda trumped strange here is
why agatha told wanda your power exceeds that
of the sorcerer supreme doctor strange sensed
the west view hex the same way agatha did and his
plan was to awaken wanda from her hex by sending
her these messages at key moments of cognition
or vulnerability in episode 1 it was the confused
phone call between wanda and vision that set up
the whole second half of the episode which led
to strange sending the message reminding wanda
of her sokovian origin which is why wanda brings
up her circovian background right after this in
episode two dr strange saw that moment dottie
broke the glass and antagonized wanda which broke
juana's reality for just a second allowing strange
to ping her with a reminder of her time with
strucker in episode three the commercial comes
right after that scene with that awkward internal
jump cut and when wanda's water breaking causes it
to rain inside at which point dr strange comes
in with the hydra soap commercial in episode 5
strange comes in with the ad for lagos paper
towels right after wanda threatens hayward
and sword to stay out of west view warning wanda
about the last time she used her chaos magic to
hurt people then in episode 6 wanda suspects
pietro as a bad influence and then shortly
after strange's commercial message is for yo magic
yogurt featuring a bro-y predator calling the kid
little dude just like pietro does there you go
little dude right on little dude this is a way
of strange telling wanda that the only way for
her to survive is to use her magic which wanda
does at the end of this episode and then the final
commercial comes in episode 7 precisely when wanda
is shocked to hear the voice of the director which
we later discover is agatha's modulated voice
behind the camera and in that moment of cognition
strange comes in to tell wanda that she is
a nexus being but in this message he includes
this warning you should not take nexus unless
your doctor has cleared you to move on with your
life and as i suspected at the time the doctor
is dr strange i think this was the commercial he
was going to appear in his message to wanda is to
wake up from the stream and consult your doctor
strange to unleash your true potential now while
this was left out of one division feige indicated
this cut meant rewrites to doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness so strange's attempts
to contact wanda inside the hex still might
be mcu canon and could get explored in that film
as the scarlet witch becomes the antagonist of
that story because in this same article elizabeth
olsen said that wanda fled westview to a place no
one would find her because she knows she's going
to be held accountable and in this post-credits
scene it's now even clearer how it ties in with
multiverse of madness doctor strange's music
wanda using astral projection a move used by
doctor strange except she's even more advanced
because she doesn't need to be asleep to do
this but notice the camera movement the camera
swoops in across the lake never cutting as it
glides into the cabin and into the back room
as if seen from the unblinking point of view
of the ever watching sorcerer supreme himself
so my friends doctor strange was not a no-show in
wanda vision westview and wanda max moth were one
of his biggest failures and as he has to face
her in multiverse of madness when the scarlet
witch reaches her nexus potential i don't think
she's gonna seek a doctor's prescription not
that anyone will be able to read it anyway i mean
even for a doctor steve's handwriting is terrible
support new rockstars by checking out one of our
many great merch options at newrockstarsmerch.com
like this shirt you can you can get it you
can be me follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos subscribe to rockstars for breakdowns
of everything marvel thank you for watching bye
you